I just finished episode four okay so the
Lannisters are the blond people and the
female lannister is married to robert
barantheon who is the king
zipper ran Theodore Baratheon right all
right and then the other blonde girl is
the can I get you something oh I don't
know um three kamikaze shots whatever I
can't believe he just did that
what's that served me before you guys
I'm really against that I'm so sorry
that's okay we got beers no I mean I'm
sorry about everything that's fine no no
it's been a hundred years of not fine I
mean 20 years ago you guys wouldn't have
even been allowed in here 20 years that
would be 1992 it was really beautiful
Oh moon said she's done that just
happened didn't it yeah amazing so the
Lannisters mm okay she's the queen Jaime
Lannister is the other one Jaime you
know what a man hey give me another
lager I mean Josh spilled my last one
I'm a tribe shirt nobody's that but
whatevs got this thing in 93 Midnight
Marauders tour check that out it's
everywhere
oh man hey who's your favorite member of
tribe smoke smoke no booze no man
nothing dude behind the scenes but yeah
he was like all right good see you guys
around though mm-hmm cool okay one more
one more
come on son boom all right they always
spun
fun second person to not wait for their
drink by the way yep oh let me ask you
this then what what's what's with the
Barbarian dude it looks like a huge Dave
Navarro because that guy oh I need a
drink
uh-huh just finished Amistad I saw it
three times and I'll see you a hundred
more times because like I'm happy to do
it if that's what those guys went
through I'm happy to sit through it you
know 300 more times or whatever you know
it takes yeah it's it so it's pretty
intense I think my thing is it's like I
don't think one person should own
another person period I'm glad that
that's what you got to hear yes yes I
mean I don't care when it happened all
right it should never happen it should
never occur but it's like I'm preaching
to the choir you guys know I'm talking
about yeah I like it's like why would
anybody even do that I'm like no you did
no you did what you doing grandma no you
did I'm ashamed
you know what it's really probably okay
because you weren't there okay well we
can come up with excuses all day all day
let's just not do that what's what's not
look hey bottom line mm-hmm we cool
right yeah all right yeah we're cool
we're kickin a cow yes
what's it like dating all right four
more years
if it makes you guys feel any better
black people make me really
uncomfortable thank you
you